mobilisation en france pour demander la
suspension de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
dans la capitale le cortège est parti du
théâtre de l'odéon direction le louvre
ce rappel de plusieurs syndicats et de
la coordination des intermittents et
précaires
ils dénoncent tous une réforme injuste
et pointe du doigt le nouveau mode de
calcul des allocations
notre reporter gaymard ozzy et d'un
cortège on le rejoint de suite et
guesnain à bonjour alors quelle est
l'ambiance actuellement
elle a écouté amira pour le moment
l'ambiance est festive malgré vous le
voyez à la météo qui a décidé de ne pas
tout à fait se mettre du côté des
manifestants alors le cortège s'est
élancé il ya maintenant plusieurs
plusieurs minutes direction comme vous
l'avez dit de le carrousel du louvre
vous voyez certainement la banderole
dernièrement et puis vous l'avez dit
vous-même des manifestants ici qui
réclame le retrait de cette réforme de
l'assurance de l'assurance chômage alors
il ya ici tous types de travailleurs des
travailleurs de nombreux secteurs de la
culture des intermittents bien entendu
mais pas seulement des intermittents qui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas concernés au
premier chef par cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage je vous le rappelle
et vous savez déjà certainement le
calcul de leur cotisation n'est pas le
même que celui des salariés du régime du
régime général mais il ya aussi tous les
tous les intérimaires tous les extras
tous les saisonniers
tous ces travailleurs précaires que l'on
appelle parfois des permis tant qu'ils y
sont nombreux à travailler aux côtés des
intermittents et c'est ainsi que vous
avez dans ce cortège deux types de
profils de manifestants vous avez donc
ses salariés précaires s'est permis tant
comme on les appelle et pour qui la
réforme de l'assurance chômage va peser
très lourdement sur leur quotidien et
qui demandent donc son retrait et vous
avez les autres les intermittents mais
aussi des retraités par exemple les
auto-entrepreneurs et qui tout
simplement viennent manifester en
solidarité avec leurs collègues l'écouté
alors actuellement je suis pas concerné
si je perds mes droits un jour je le
saurai comme ce que je tomberai dans la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui est
en train de se mettre en place et donc
mes indemnités seront gravement baissé
parce que je serais plus couverts par ce
statut particulier l'intermittence du
spectacle donc chose solidarité par le
fait qu'en fait il n'y a pas d' écoute
de la part du gouvernement qui est en
place oui en effet on est les
intermittents présent parce qu'on est ce
qu'ils sont les plus aptes à s'exprimer
et on est là pour soutenir plein
d'autres systèmes qui sont en cause
comme l'hôtellerie le tourisme plein de
mouvements qui sont arrêtés et qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit des aides
actuellement et avec la réforme qui
arrive en avoir encore moins cette
réforme
elle devrait améliorer les conditions de
vie et les revenus des chômeuses et des
chômeurs c'est exactement l'inversé
qu'elle fait elle diminue ce que les
chômeuses et les chômeurs vont recevoir
et
pire encore elle diminue le nombre de
gens qui vont pouvoir recevoir des
indemnités de chômage
c'est donc tout à fait inacceptable et
concernant cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage je vous invite à venir à jeun
vite vos téléspectateurs à revenir à
revoir ou avoir le sujet de katia
technique qui revient en détails et
justement sur cette réforme
et pour finir était hier matin ce sont
sept syndicats au premier rang desquels
au cgt mais également ses feux cgc ont
déposé un recours en référé devant le
conseil d'état
il espère la suspension voire carrément
l'annulation le retrait de cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage par la hauteur la
plus haute juridiction administrative
merci à guillaume ahond se retrouvent de
toutes façons lors de notre prochaine
édition en espérant que la météo soit un
peu plus clémente cette fois ci